hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday
monday morning podcast why are you doing
it bill cause i'm just checking in on
you
that's all i'm doing here sitting here
by myself at the end of the night had a
great night tonight
great night you know i went out with the
family the family bag each
went out got something to eat and my
daughter was just making my son laugh
his ass off
and uh this woman
at the table next to us said oh your
daughter's funny and i was just like yes
whoa
i was awesome
afterwards we were hanging out you know
my wife was handling the check because
we're a progressive couple
um no cause i'm the dad and she goes
these kids are driving me nuts go take
them down by the car while i
[__] close up shop here so i'm like
all right
so we're down there and there's these
rocks and both my kids were just picking
the rocks up and firing them as hard as
they could into the woods it was awesome
it was just really awesome to see you
know and uh
i think they're both gonna be you know
into sports and stuff my daughter is
like crazy for skateboarding and [__]
it's awesome it's just awesome seeing
that they're gonna be uh you know
you know doing that type of stuff
because i swear to god if they both got
into books i'd be sitting there like uh
are these my kids
[Music]
um
anyway oh jesus [__] what a sad week
what a [__] sad week man still have
not even begun to deal with the shock
of losing bob saget it's just so [__]
brutal um
[__] brutal [__] brutal and the
amount of dumb [__] that people are
saying is is it the new thing now any
time a celebrity dies like betty white
dies and they go that's cause she got
the booster
it's so [__] they're just so [__]
yeah who the [__] knows betty white
on the internet some random [__]
person oh yeah she was hanging out with
you
like how to [__] no none of these people
know any of these people that they're
[__] talking about
and uh
i don't know but you gotta blame modern
medicine just for their existence
because that's what has kept them alive
or their parents alive so that they
could [__] and then make them so that
they could then go on the internet
and express their ideas
you know and build their brand and and
just cultivate this sea of [__]
morons
[__] morons you know and this is
coming somebody went to summer school
almost every year i should have gone
every year in high school but i just
quit in the end
senior year is like well what's the
point man
so i can get into a little better
community college
um
anyway but
it's actually got to be honest with it's
kind of a good thing to uh every once in
a while be on the inside of something
and then listen to [__] idiots who
are on the outside and just watch them
come up with these [__] theories
uh
everything anything you're doing there's
tv shows movies documentaries putting on
a benefit
uh somebody gets mad about something and
comes up with this angle of [__]
horseshit and these people just they
just run with it
they just run with it and it's unf the
[__] that they [__] you know there's
people on the internet
who speak for dead comedians like they
know what dead comics are saying and
what they're thinking
people who never met them
constantly
will be [__] tweeting or will tweet
to me
about a dead friend that i have and what
they're thinking it's like that is an
amazing
amazing ability
ain't something go like
you know the fact that i've been
listening to uh you know i decided to go
with the mainstream on this one right
you know and i don't give a [__] if
you're going the other way god bless you
i hope you're i hope you're right i hope
you're right
i hope it is just a cold um
but i went with the mainstream one and
somebody wrote
they told me
with absolute confidence what george
carlin would be thinking of me right now
[Music]
it's just like oh gee that's an
incredible uh that's an incredible
ability you have uh what would abraham
lincoln be thinking
can you do presidents too or do you just
you just do can you do dead presidents
or just dead comedians
you know was it like doctors
some are foot doctors and others are
heart doctors
others are internet doctors the internet
doctors i'll tell you about them they
have command of the entire body where
doctors who actually went to medical
school seem to just you know realize the
body's so complex that they just break
off into one area
that they need specialists
because that's how complex it is unless
you didn't go to the medical school and
you're on the internet
then
then you know everything or
if you were a doctor and you were kicked
out of mainstream
the mainstream medical air that those
are my favorite [__] people because
they kicked him out because he's telling
the truth man it's like okay
i'll go with that i'm not i'm not gonna
defend big pharmaceutical on any level
not say that they're evil [__] that
didn't kill a bunch of people
okay but you just can't automatically
then assume that everyone who got kicked
out is good
some people get kicked out because
they're reckless
because they killed a patient because
they did a procedure that didn't need to
be done because they wanted to buy a
ferrari
i swear to god i watch american greek i
know what i'm talking about
seriously i'm [__] around but like uh
a number of episodes on american greed
were people in the medical field
who wanted to live
there was this [__] guy that moved to
the middle of [__] nowhere
i forget why he did it he just thought
that he could get a lot of victims out
there and he just did all of these
[__] procedures and [__] up all of
these people's lives
and was just making incredible
incredible amounts of money in the
middle that's what did him in
uh
i don't know if he got high in his own
supply or he didn't
you know
if he underestimated the other guy's
greed whatever that frank lopez speech
was i don't know what he did
but uh he got a little too [__] crazy
with it and they ended up figuring out
hey man
you live in the middle of [__] you
know south dakota and with a population
of about 200 people and you did uh
19.8 million dollars last year when uh
medical uh stuff
uh was there an avalanche out here was
there some sort of plane crash where
where exactly did you get what do you
and he's like any [__] guy just takes
off goes to florida
you know
that's where all the rebels go florida
all the weak people go to california to
try to get sitcoms like me
but all the rebels all the true [__]
you know
the people that know what's going on man
they go down to [__]
they go down florida that's where it's
done hey if you were gonna bail
if you're gonna bail on your life like
you're like you know what
i'm sick of the rat race i'm getting the
[__]
out of here where would you go
and what would your fake name be if for
some reason like whatever they
there wasn't social media in the
internet where people would [__] rat
you out and stuff
you know
i'm trying to think where i would i
think i would go to tennessee
i think tennessee's like perfect
perfect climate
you know
they got the beautiful mountains on the
east
i wouldn't go to nashville though
there's too many [__] people in
nashville
i go wherever that [__] f-100 thing
is every year that i keep saying i'm
gonna go to and i never [__] make it
it's a big f-100 show
in one of those small towns in tennessee
i would i would live like [__] 10
miles outside of it like uncle jesse
or cooter on dukes of hazard i would
live out there off a [__] dirt road
now that'd be too scary i'm too much of
a city kid i couldn't [__] deal with
that
you know what i mean
the [__] wildlife out there
i've listened to too many country songs
what was that charlie daniel's one about
the [__] old guy that buried all the
money in the [__] mason jars
and the people went out there to kill
him
and they threw him in the [__] swamp
to get eaten by the that's probably down
north uh [__] new orleans
they threw him in the [__]
what was it the swamp or some [__] to
get eaten by the alligators
they picked up the mason jars
and then they went into quicksand
and the last thing they heard was the
old guy cackling laughing as they went
under
you know what i learned on my last
little trip here
i learned
that uh you actually
you don't sink
all the way under like they have it in
hollywood
it's just another one of hollywood's
lies man
because your body is like whatever you
whatever percentage of water
once you get up to about your waist to
your chest you just sort of float
you just gotta kind of muck your way out
of it
um i actually walked in quicksand on my
last little trip there i didn't tell you
about my vacation man i had a great
[__] time
i had a great time scary time too you
know just seeing
you know i was out in utah
and i was seeing the colorado river and
how [__] dried up it is it's just
unbelievable what is happening to the
environment
and how none of these [__] news
places
uh stations pay attention to it even
remotely
because all of their [__] advertisers
are part of the [__] problem that's
drying it up or so many of them are
you know i think that's why they always
go after comedians because we're just
[__] easy targets
did you hear this joke the guy said at
the comedy zone i mean what is this what
is happening to this country
was it worse than [__] the colorado
river not reaching the ocean for the
last 20 years or whatever
was the joke worse than that is that
what it was anyway i was out there so um
you know i'm a sober guy now except when
i go out to the desert
so i did some mushrooms and man i got to
tell you something i had a [__] blast
i had such a good [__] time and what
i love about those things is i only have
the desire to do them like once a year
or once you know i only do them if like
i'm with my wife
and we're [__] in the middle of
nowhere my kids aren't there so it's
just like all right
i don't have any responsibility
i feel safe out here this [__] nature
man and uh
oh my god i had such a good [__] time
they kicked in and like right behind
where we was staying it literally looked
like a cliff
that wiley coyote would [__] jump off
of
you know
and all those rocks became like an
audience and i was just talking to them
and [__]
i was having i never got freaked out i
just enjoyed
the whole everything was [__] moving
it was wild and then i came in and i sat
down
and i watched the chargers raiders game
just tripping balls
and i just it was [__] amazing
because you're tripping and then you
come out of it and then you go back into
it and you're like oh good it's not over
um
it was such a great game and i actually
was watching it i knew what was
happening it just never it just didn't
look like any football game i'd ever
seen before
you know the announcer's faces were
[__] all weird and their heads were
going into their shirts and [__]
and i was i was making my wife laugh her
ass off
because at one point i think
collinsworth was saying you know the
chargers biggest problem tonight is
going to be and i was thinking yeah well
your biggest problem is your [__]
head's going into your shirt
it was amazing i had such i had such a
[__] great time i was actually sad
when it was over
it was incredible and then i uh
yeah i just did what i always do is just
like all right
now i mean last time i [__]
the only other time i did them
i was immediate i mean i had a bad trip
and i was like i need to figure out
what's wrong with me
and i was basically stoned sober until
for 11 months
and now i did them again
and now i have no desired
you know i don't it's not going to go
start drinking again or [__] smoke
weed or anything i'm just like that was
fun so i think that's going to be my
thing man
i think once every year year and a half
whenever i get time and my wife gets
tired and we [__] go away somewhere
you know
if the kids are there i'm not doing it
but every once in a while if i'm out in
[__] nature man it's [__] fun
as hell i get it
i [__] get it
[Laughter]
good times to be had
dude i was standing there right
and it's weird when the [__] comes on
all of a sudden everything around you
was just like alive and i'm like all
right hey how's it going
good to see you guys again this is
literally what i remember saying and
then i kind of saw something moving
out to the left i was like hey buddy
didn't see you over there i was talking
to him like they were people
[Laughter]
[Music]
i kind of told this story on anything
better but i'll tell you guys just i'll
tell it again just in case because i
don't think you guys all listened to
anything better also
with paul verzi so
when i first walked out there
you know i it started coming on i
started hearing like voices
and we were on like you know navajo
or near it anyways
the land that the government you know
gave them
after they stole it and after we all
stole it right
and uh
i was hearing these voices and i was
thinking like oh my god because i
couldn't make out what they were saying
i was like wait a minute am i hearing
the spirits and the [__] indians that
used to be here
and all of a sudden i saw this movement
in the hills and i was like
the [__] is that
is that like because i'm tripping or is
that actually
a person
and it looked like a person i was like
and then they kind of look like a cowboy
i'm like is that a [__] cowboy wait
did i just open a porthole into the
[__] 1800s like what's going on here
man
and then out of nowhere the cowboy just
stopped and looked at me and he just
goes
hello
he was way away from me
and it felt like he was like right next
to me
and i was like what the [__] i didn't
know you heard [__] and saw stuff
this is amazing
and then i hear him talking to this
woman
she goes alright be careful i love you
and he's like okay and he starts walking
away
and starts walking sort of parallel to
the rocks that i'm looking at and i'm
like what the [__]
so i go back into the little bungalow
and i'm like nia
i go can you go outside and tell me if
there's a cowboy walking across the
backyard
so she starts cracking up laughing you
know she didn't do it like she just let
me do it
um
so she [__] goes out there
she goes
there's nobody out there and she's
laughing her ass off
and i was like what the [__]
and i told her the whole story it's like
i didn't know you like heard voices and
all this is [__] insane
so i sat down at eight and then that's
when i sat down and i watched the
[__]
the raiders chargers and they showed
like the beginning and they were like
panning around that stadium with all the
lights and stuff
and i was like what the [__]
[Music]
and i'm going this is amazing and nia
god bless her she was sitting there
because she was afraid i was going to
have a bad trip or whatever
um
because of the sadness of the past week
you know that was the day when bob i
found out bob passed and uh
but like i just
you know i just said to myself i'm not
gonna think about that sad stuff i'm
just gonna have a good time
um
not to mention i had already taken him
when i found out
that he had passed and i was like oh
[__] this is gonna be brutal but i don't
know
maybe some of bob's happiness
was in me i don't know what so anyway
i have a great time
um
and then the next morning we wake up we
go to the communal area where there's
breakfast right and when we finish
breakfast
as we're getting up to leave i see the
cowboy come walking in
except he wasn't dressed like a cowboy
he was just dressed like a [__]
person from 2022.
and i go near
she's like what and i'm like that's the
[__] cowboy i saw last night except
he's not wearing cowboy clothes
and she goes what i go i think that's
the guy i saw last night i don't think i
saw a cowboy i think it was that guy
and she starts cracking up
and we breakfast ends
and we walk back up to where we're
staying and then that guy pulled up in a
golf cart and he was in the bungalow
right next to me
and that's when i realized i didn't see
a cowboy i saw that guy
and that guy saw me and he said hello to
me because he saw me looking at him and
i didn't say hello back to him because i
didn't think he was real
[Music]
oh [__]
so there you go
that's my mushroom story
um
it was such a [__]
a [__] good time man
it was such a good time
uh
but like i said if you guys are all
worried because i've been you know
pretty much a sober guy
i haven't sober you know i mean i was
[__] with weed you know
2018 i quit booze and then i slowly was
replacing it
with weed and then i was like i got to
stop this [__]
but i wasn't and then i took mushrooms
and then i stopped
and then well i guess so 11 months i
didn't do anything
and then i took mushrooms again and then
i was coming back
worried that i'd be going hey let's get
some [__] weed and i haven't and i've
had no desire to do it
so uh
it's pretty [__] cool
um
that you can have an experience like
that and it doesn't at least for how
it's working for me
is it doesn't make me want to go back
and be a [__] idiot again um
you know plus having my kids here really
helps it's like i'm not i just could
never get past that was like
you know
the end of my drinking days when i was
downstairs watching like me tv and i'd
be getting shit-faced and my daughter
was upstairs and i'm like if somebody
came in right now something happened to
her like i can't [__] i'm legally
shit-faced
like what am i doing i'm gonna be that
guy
oh daddy liked his scotch i was like i
can't be that guy
so
anyway um
let's do uh
let's do some of the reads here for this
week oh look who it is our old friends
here
do me undies me undies look at that
[__] guy doo doo doo doo me undies me
undies he's looking right into my eyes
but he looks like the lone ranger i'm
not sure
i'm not saying hi back
cure but then you see him at breakfast
and he gives you a look
and says look at that's that bald rude
prick who didn't say hello but i bet he
had on his [__] me undies
all right meundies is someone you love
in a relationship with somebody who
tells the same joke over and over
oh my god
my wife would have a field day with that
line or are they with somebody who has
the audacity
to starfish the bed
um
nobody has the audacity they either they
just starfish in the bed because they're
trying to get comfortable then it's up
to you
to [__] say hey [__]
why don't you pull in your limbs there
instead of audacity maybe they're
testing you to see if you have the inner
strength
you know if you're going to claim your
rightful half of the bed
or you're going to be somebody that they
can control uh now be honest is this
somebody you
relationships are not perfect
that's why me undies is celebrating our
imperfectly perfect matches with their
new valentine's day collection
gifting underwear for valentine's day
groundbreaking ah [__] is that coming up
already
these [__] corporate [__] do they
give you a goddamn [__] month off
we just got through the [__] holiday
season
jesus [__] christ
dude valentine's day is such a [__]
kick in the seeds every year it's like
you're just getting your bills coming in
from [__] christmas and then hey you
know you gotta let her know again for
what it's not her birthday
gifting underwear for valentine's day
groundbreaking i love it sounds cheap to
me let's do it but gifting but gifting
matching underwear to for you and your
significant other now we're talking i
know that sounds stupid to a lot of you
guys but it's great
because they know that you think it's
stupid but they think it's cute so if
you do it anyway you get points
and they might get so lost in the
dopamine of oh
you did that for us that they'll not
realize that you barely spent any money
express your one of the kind
relationship uh when you match your
bottom half to your better half in fun
limited edition prints i'm gonna do this
if you're single mingle in matching
pairs
with your friends or family
doesn't that mean you want to bang your
friend or family if we're [__] you're
going to start off with
i don't know that was that you could you
should have put that first
you know
before talking about intimate
relationships you can even get dog
hoodies
oh great now bc ellie or buddy bands
to match your four-legged bff
oh my god there's one there's a one-way
ticket to jerk off town
me and my dog wear the same underwear oh
is that what you do great
uh be sure to check out all of me undies
super cute and super soft undies socks
bralettes
loungewear i'm into the loungewear i
like that [__] and more avail and more
available in sizes from extra small
to 4xl
uh meundies has a great offer for my
listeners for a limited time only you
get 25 off your first order
the only thing that gives orders is
balls uh first order of matching pairs
for valentine's day
uh i'm gonna look these up after i do
this next read
and as a first time purchaser you can
also get 15 off in free shipping right
to your door to get 25 off matching
pairs 15 off your first order free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guarantee
go to meundies.com
that's meundies.com
burr
all right a couple more here all right
roman
you know when the moment for intimacy
arrives you need to be ready
all right roman ready
whether you've been in a relationship
for years or you're just getting started
having the confidence that comes from
preparation means you're free to enjoy
the moment when the moment comes
this is hilarious you take this [__]
and your dick is just ready to go
it's just listening to your spitting
game the whole night like come on
open the [__] door let's go
like a paratrooper
like what's his face in state of grace
let's [__] go
even though you are far from ordinary
the truth is that erectile dysfunction
is really common in fact 52 percent of
guys age forty to seventy seventy yeah
experience some form of erectile
dysfunction
go to get roman.com
slash bird now
to speak to a u.s licensed health care
professional about erectile dysfunction
and get 15 off your first month of
treatment roman's system is completely
confidential and totally discreet no big
logos or labels on packages with roman
you can get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for erectile dysfunction
all from the comfort and privacy of your
own home a u.s licensed health care
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships to you free within
with two-day shipping
go to get roman r-o-m-a-n-dot-com
today and if you're prescribed get 15
off your first month of ed treatment
make sure you're ready to have
confidence and control this fall
roman ready isn't that great
you're going bald they can fix that
your dick's [__] staring at the
ground having the blues they can fix
that i mean it's [__] amazing it's
amazing what they can do
you're here standing up all spiky your
[__] dick saluting your hairline
be a whole new man
all right simply safe everybody you know
if you've ever wanted to make your home
feel safer there's no better time than
right now right now our friends it's
simply safe for giving my listeners
access to all their new year's holiday
deals
20 percent up
sorry 20 off their award-winning home
security and your first month is free
when you sign up for the interactive
monitoring service i love simply safe
because it has everything you need to
make your home safe indoor and outdoor
cameras which are great it's also
awesome if you watch like late at night
you can see like [__] varmint ufc
going down with raccoons fighting over
your [__] garbage and chasing off
squirrels
um makes great youtube videos i love
simply safe uh because it has everything
you need to make your home safe indoor
and outdoor cameras comprehensive
sensors all monitored around the clock
by trained professionals
who send help the instant you need it
simply safe was even named best home
security system of 2021 by u.s news and
world report you can easily customize a
system
for your home online in minutes and even
get free custom recommendations there
are no long-term contracts or
commitments it's a really easy way to
get started to start feeling a bit more
peace of mind in the new year hurry take
20 off your simply safe system and your
first month is free when you sign up for
the interactive monitoring service visit
simplysafe.com
again that's simplysafe.com
twenty dollars off your entire system
all right i'm gonna look up two things
here we're gonna go to me undies
me undies me undies
valentine's day hey hey
let's see what they got here meundies
newest prince
all right let's see what they got for
the match me just the way you are look
at that they got a couple of ladies
look at them being all progressive
lesbian love right off the bat
a couple of [__] white people
she's got dyed hair so you know he's got
a tattoo look at them they're [__]
cutting edge and then down in the
right-hand corner they have the
impossibly good-looking young couple
i mean they really they hit everything
there
all right so where is it
match me just the way you are shop gift
shop gift guide all right
all right we're back to the lesbians
all right
shredded asian guy
they just got everything going on here
all right i don't know what i don't even
know what what i'm okay here we go
all right
ugh you know what i hate i [__] can't
stand
is sex in food combined
it's just so [__] gross
you know that remember that nine and a
half weeks when he was banging her in
the kitchen and he's just [__]
wasting all that food it's just like
what are you doing
well you ever go to a titty bar and they
go you guys want some wings it's like no
if i wanted wings i go to a restaurant
[__] eating your food here
um
oh there's the matching ones
jesus christ
they should have a [__]
link to a treadmill on this goddamn
thing
all right
i get it
okay
i'm just old okay that's not what
underwear models used to look like when
i was a kid
underwear models used to make you feel
bad about yourself
all right now uh rapper bangs
girlfriend
at
uh what the [__] was it it was at a a
hockey game
was this real or was this just made up
oh he's not okay he wasn't having sex at
an nhl game
he was just messing around oh
i see it
this website uses cookies oh is that
what it does
caught up black try tricks people that
think he's having sex at an nhl game
all right well that's not exciting
i remember when i was a kid
there was uh
what the [__] was it not when i was a
kid it was a little i don't know
probably when i was in my 20s makes me
feel like a kid
this couple at a concert jumped up on
stage you want to talk about roman ready
she bends over and the guy was just
banging her in front of the whole
[__] crowd
there's got to be a picture of that one
couple
bangs on stage at rock
concert
let's see here
some results may be explicit oh you
think so
um
there was none of these ones
i can't find it
it was like
all right couple performed sex act on
stage at punk's rock concert
all right
that just makes it worse if they just
said they banged it's like a sex act
couple has sex on stage at a norwegian
music festival oh this is not like an
original idea
uh
lead singer [__] his fan girl on stage
at rock show
well the band plays and dances around
them the hippie chick gets [__]
hardcore on stage by the lead singer
it says she is a great figure and
clearly loves i'm going to say that this
oh it's voyer style oh that's all
[__]
the bang story from the basement all
right
i swear to god i saw a picture of it a
long [__] time ago
and i was amazed
i was just like that i mean
talk about like in the moment and not
giving a [__]
be funny if you did it and everybody
started bowing
[Laughter]
um anyway
all right
that is the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast um
now we're gonna do oh jesus we're gonna
do a clip you're gonna hear a quick
version of my mushroom story i apologize
uh
it's gonna be i forget if you listen to
this that's oh this is just a clip this
is from the uh oh no this won't be in
this this is just our picks this is the
episode you get to hear who won
the jimmy the greek award
um with uh me and verzi picking four
games against the spread
battling with each other through 18
weeks of nfl football we had a great
time
it came right down to the wire
all right here it is have a listen
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better
uh nfl preview show the last show the
regular season is done but uh we have
the playoffs uh starting right now guys
and as you know
uh by now we've teamed up with bet mgm
this season we'll be using bet mgm lines
to make all of our picks and we'll have
special offers for our listeners each
week if you haven't signed up yet uh for
bet mgm just use a bonus code burr
you'll get 200 free after placing your
first 10 bets here's how it works you
download the bet mgm app you sign up
using bonus code bur that's b-u-r-r
could not be more easy you place your
first 10 money line bet uh any nfl game
you'll receive 200 in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome just make sure
you use bonus code burr that's b-u-r-r
um but
yes we will go over a dramatic ending to
our regular season and we will get into
um this is how dramatic it is i don't
even know who won
it's flip-flopped like three times who
won dude hold on let's we're gonna get
into what happened because something
wild happened
um
we're gonna get into that and we're
gonna do our wild card picks now we're
gonna do
you know your mic's off your mic is off
lost your pole start
can't hear you
you gotta post that
we cannot hear you
this is like watching somebody flip out
in the car next to you
you can't hear what they're saying
we i was we're trying to tell bill
what's going on with the things so let's
we should pause this and tell them
everything tell me just keep going
what's going on so here's what happened
last night
i did all the math i watched every
[__] episode because there were some
discrepancies andrew had said that i won
by half a game i said i gotta look at
that i can't i can't i'm not winning any
stupid [__] like this if we don't if
it's not sure i went over the games last
night when i went over the games last
night
uh and i [__] wrote it all like i'm
10 hours in i'm like why isn't he just
fast forwarded
my wife just said what the f i wasted
all because i wanted to make sure cause
i was like i don't know man i don't want
anything so anyways
went to bed last night i was trying to
do the math you were you had a half a
game lead i sent it to andrew and bet
mgm and i told him that and then they
had told me that i took the packers in
week eight
and uh i counted it as a loss but it was
a win but hey paul guess what guess what
i don't give a [__] bill
no dude what about bill dude
dude you did something bill that [__]
hurt you go like this you go all right
then [__] it in week nine you go [__] it
dude then i'm taking the bills i'm
taking the bills and then at the very
end you go nah then i'll just go
head-to-head cardinals and that was your
4-0 and that's the game that we start we
didn't have but yeah but i did something
stupid also when you were just like
there's the [__] with urban meyer
there's no way jacksonville this is a
lock and just bumped me so just out of
spite i took that [__] game so you go
get it because you wanted to debunk it
um yes we're no no
that's one of my life missions paul
what's that
telling gamblers that they don't there's
no such thing as a lock
well here's the thing because when
gamblers talk about a lock oh my god i
[__] bob about they only talk about
the victories paul
those other locks that don't make it
they don't add that into their average
um
i gotta say something before we get into
this wildcard weekend
watching our show for 18 episodes i just
did the pics so it was literally only
like 10 minutes each thing so it was
only a couple hours but watching it
i almost called you to say this but i
know you don't like to take compliments
and i know that you're busy so the last
thing you wanted to do dude you said
things during that [__] show that
were so [__] on and precise that if
you look back it's like futuristic [__]
and uh i knew i was smart
dude you said a couple of things about
coaches and you said a couple of things
about shootouts and you said a couple of
things about teams that were on the road
and i was just going dude guys the last
week uh i got to tell you i'm at the
falcon saints game i don't know what's
going on and all i know is
like a non-winner i go 0-4
i [__] stumble to the thing and then
i look at bill and bill's 0-3 and i go
oh [__] we may both [__] just crap
out and of course
bill bill goes to the gift that keeps on
[__] giving which is tom brady the
game was close into the third quarter
and the bucks ended up winning but now
that i lost money on him all year every
time i took them they [__] the bed
yeah and every time i took the cardinals
they should oh and here are our go-to i
want money on the car
who are you go to sister you know so the
go-to is after i went through all the
weekends and i wrote everything down
bill went hard
bill loved the cardinals i loved the
steelers
okay
what yeah bill loved the seahawks
bill you liked the seahawks even when
they were like no chance you were like
no but they covered dude they covered a
lot
no yeah you you like them the the i i
loved the packers i was a big packers
um but i love the bills in the beginning
i got on the colts bandwagon carson
wentz scores points and then i i wrote
that too long eventually they [__] you
uh
another thing i took from it is
the head to heads dude i just i beat i
think once or twice you beat me like
four times in the head to heads
um but then you beat me yeah you beat me
like twice something like that but one
but now the playoff picture is done
everybody and uh we have in the afc
the las vegas raiders playing
playing joe burrow
do the thing
in that game is in cincy we have your
new england patriots on the road in
buffalo
that's the uh saturday night game
and then sunday the philadelphia eagles
are going to get there
are going to see sayonara to tom brady
and the tampa bay uh bucks that's the
one o'clock game sunday and then uh oh
boy you got the san francisco 49ers and
the cowboys in dallas that's a great
game
and then you have um
the pittsburgh steelers at the chiefs
and your arizona cardinals at the rams
that's what the playoff picture looks
like right now and bill this is the fun
time where we get the t-shirt cardinals
rams game is the game for me all right
well the cardinals rams game we're going
to do some teases for the fans and me
and bill can do this together so we're
going to oh by the way real quick the
last thing i got to say we closed out
the year hitting our third monday night
special we had a lot of people betting
we made the money and guys how many
sports shows done by comedians when they
both beat the book
okay they're both over how many done by
people who are actually in sports they
pick against the [__] money line
no no dude me and you both beat the book
after 72 games of picking and we hit
three monday night specials who does
that we need a raw article about that
can we get michael o'brien on it like no
comedians are doing this
i don't [__] again i can't [__] look
at the did i just go to bed mgm
yeah oh here it is i'm an idiot there it
is it
i got it what i like to do and i think
bet mgm likes us to do it too and i
think it's the best way to do it is
teasing games we get six points to play
with each way
and uh
i don't like teas and paul okay you know
where you stand with me i don't play
games
what about this stuff
what about let's do a two-team we have a
monday night playoff game jesus christ
that's incredible what about
i like giving the patriots six because
then they have ten and a half
and then we put another team with six
one you like the patriot i like the
patriots getting ten and a half in
buffalo you
i lie i like that i don't know that game
scares me i will i will i would tease
the [__] bengals in a second
okay you want to tease the bengals you
want to tease the bangles down to
getting one
yeah i do that and i'll tease you i'll
tease the patriots getting 10 and a half
i think that that's gonna be a
[__] of a game i think at the
end of the day
i think the head coach with the talent
that he has
um
i think the you know whoever wins that
game they're gonna they're gonna they're
gonna eke it out that's gonna be a
that's gonna be a nail biter so i love
the best dude this is the best me and
bill get to team forces and do these
teases so there you go andrew they're
for the better team forces join forces
paul
yeah you know i mean so here's the thing
hey paul karma's the thing
we're going to take the new england
patriots just to repeat sir but the new
we're gonna do a two team tease new
england patriots getting ten and a half
in buffalo and the simpson and the
cincinnati bengals getting one at home
against the raiders the greatest
all right bill
which team do you think has a better
chance of getting upset
tampa bay against the eagles
or the chiefs against the steelers
oh [__]
well listen
i love a cowboy movie like anybody
so
i want to see the old gunslinger
come in against the chiefs
uh i'll tell you this this is what this
is my feeling on the chiefs cowboy
versus indian baby
that's right
steel worker versus [__] arrowhead
um i think if if the if the chiefs
[__] snap out of it
and kick the [__] out of the steelers
they're going to the super bowl or
they're going to lose this week i don't
think there's i don't think there's that
they they're either gonna just [__] the
bed the first week against the steelers
or they're going back to the super bowl
that's what i think
um
well andrew how many games did he want
us to do they wants to do like two games
or three games
whatever you want to do as many let's
pick them off
yeah all right go down and pick them
yeah just pick them off all right what
are you already
where's the game at it's an arrowhead
well we yeah we already took the first
two on a tease so let's talk
philadelphia bucks
the buccaneers are eight and a half
point favorites
at the old sombrero
and um the eagles you know the eagles
got in kind of barely there you know i
don't know you know
jalen hurts as a quarterback i mean i
like brady and them to win the game do
they win by 10
probably
i would tease the eagles up
you would tease the eagles up
more points yeah i just don't think the
tampa bay's been consistent
dude we could tease it down to two and a
half though
wait the eagles are getting points right
yeah but we could also tease the the
bucks down to two and a half having to
win by a field goal
oh we we could do it we can the six
points hey listen it's our six points we
do what we want with it
um
i think the eagles are going to play
them good
i really do i don't know why i haven't
got i haven't had a feel for [__]
tampa bay the whole year they look like
they're going to going to go
back-to-back and then they look like
they're going to [__] the bed the same
thing with like the the chiefs every
time the chiefs look like they were dead
and buried it looked like they figured
it out again
um you know what you know what you
rolled with me on my first tease i'll
roll with you on this we could do the
philadelphia eagles getting
what would that pain it would what it
was uh it's eight and a half andrew
right plus yeah so they'd get six they'd
be 14 and a half i'll take the eagles in
14 and a half okay so take the eagles
over two touchdowns which is good 14 and
a half
and i say we tease dallas
dallas can't lose that game wait what
about the chief steelers we got to tease
that one too
let's tease him up paul no we could
tease the steelers one with the
cardinals and rams
so six games
all right but what who did we tease the
uh the tampa tampa game with yeah we're
gonna that's that's what we could decide
that now you want to do okay so you want
to do the tampa game with the steelers
game
oh i see you know what i would do i
would tease the two two games i'm not
the most sure of i would tease together
rather than have it take down two bets
i like that that's a better's mentality
i like that so what so so you're saying
that the ones that you don't know too
well would be the steelers in chiefs
yeah that that one is a [__] of
a game
uh you want to give you want to give the
steelers 18 and a half
big ben and mike tomlin are they going
to lose by 20.
and dude is kansas city going to [__]
beat the steal like i just big ben i
think big ben they're going to play for
big ben listen the last time they played
was three weeks ago in kc and casey beat
the [__] out of him
bad
like blow
my only knock against the steelers is
they they're always like this is what we
do
all right we totally defeated it we're
gonna keep doing it
um
i think the chiefs down tease the chiefs
down
all right
all right it's your bet i like it
i like it either way actually all right
and keep the chiefs down and tease the
eagles up
all right now we're gonna do the 49ers
cowboys
oh dude this is the game the arizona
cardinals los angeles rams this is the
game okay so let's see so hold on i just
want to make sure it's written down so
andrew eagle's 14 and a half
chiefs
minus six and a half
because we're taking that down six okay
now we got two more games san francisco
49ers at dallas arizona cardinals at the
los angeles rams
rams are four and a half point favorites
in los angeles
cardinals are coming up cardinals are
coming off a [__] loss
um
which i know all too well
i like the ramps in this game i like
their front four i do um
i don't know what's going on with the
cardinals i actually think tyler murray
might be a little hurt he's got
something nagging on him
i don't know what's going on with them
i'd i i take i would tease the uh
the rams down to getting two and a half
and then the this is just my opinion
probably you have to go with this i love
49ers man
i love that i love that bet by the way i
love the rams t's down getting points
that front four at home i love that
all right cowboys 49ers buddy this is
the toughest this is a tough
tough one but i i think the cowboys win
the game they can't have another first
exit dak prescott's playing great why
can't they paul it's what they've been
doing through [__]
ever since jimmy johnson has left
well what's his face barry switzer got
him through
um
all right whatever you want it's the mid
90s paul paul since we both had full
heads of hair dallas cowboys have just
not delivered
dude that's a great [__] thing we got
to have our listeners
so we we want to see how successful your
team is
by your part you got to have a picture
of you now and then the last time they
they [__] won a playoff game dude
that is great anything better listeners
yes you have to hold a picture of the
year on throwback thursday that is epic
andrew where can they send that to
i wasn't born i gotta i might i don't
know last time they played me but they
won like a playoff game what did a run
oh okay 99 maybe so that would be no
yeah 99 was with spreewell when they
played the spurs i gotta find a picture
marcus camby i love that team anything
anything better podcast at gmail do that
one okay guys there you go send your
pictures of you holding yourself a
picture of yourself of your t1 anything
better podcast that gmail and we'll
we'll uh what we can't do all of it
we'll put like we'll put like 10 funny
we'll put up the funniest ones dude
there's gonna be some rough ones that's
a great call
um i like this is what i like bill i
like the rams like you said down i like
the cowboys getting three at home in
texas but if you want to go up i like
the other one too i like the niners
getting nine i like it either way
ooh niners getting nine
niners
jimmy g's playing is he playing though
how's he been doing the last few weeks
oh no dude he came back and beat us they
were dude they were down 17 nothing
against the rams that's the savage they
have on the defensive line is he back is
he healthy hubosa yeah
that i don't know
andrew can i have that information
considering i don't know [__] how
many wins i have and how many losses oh
i'm gonna protest that paul i'm gonna
whine about that like jim irsay by the
way dude how good looking is jimmy
garoppolo that kid came up with his suit
in a press conference tan i was just
like this kid is crushing it
yeah
the only thing he didn't have was a you
know you know what i would wear bill in
a press conference i'd wear black
turtleneck jacket chain outside the
turtleneck
[Laughter]
uh he's he's playing
he's playing he's playing is he healthy
yeah says healthy post acl tear
well how long has he been back
um
i think is that guy healthy is a [__]
problem
oh wait a minute
um
relatively healthy across roster that's
what it says yes uh a couple soon
i don't know paul is this the year the
cowboys finally do it i mean i don't
know i like 49ers with nine better than
i like the cowboys getting three because
i think it's gonna be obviously a close
game
so why not take nine points instead of
just getting three
okay
i would i will i'll roll that way i i
like to count i feel like i'm in like
you're like a battered wife this week
you're not making any decision i'm
making all of these [__] you just
i like i like dallas better but but i'll
roll but i the niners getting nine is
cool all right but i feel like we went
with everything that i said so you want
you wanna you want the cowboys
let's do the cowboys getting three and
the rams getting two and a half i i like
that damn cowboys you know what both are
home both wanna you know i i like that i
also think the cowboys rested up for
this game
i like it well i got a good i got a good
promo picture for us
i dress like tom landry and you dress
like jimmy johnson
because that's how we are i'm all
[__] stoic with the fedora and you're
more you're more with the chain out how
about damn cowboys dude here's what we
got to do before next year's before next
year's competition starts me and bill
should shoot a a photo promo out there
where we're different coaches and
different years
different like we'll go look at players
that we look like dude that would be
nuts dude well i look like the punter
and i on on
houston everybody says and
and uh the guy uh sean what's his face
from the bills oh dude we'll put a
bill's jacket on you with what he wears
on the sidelines for the bills and the
hat that'll be hilarious then we'll do
one where uh yeah you're like landry and
no no who's the guy you look like one of
the you look like if we got you a wig
you could play the guy he was he was the
browns coach remember that time he's
going one time
one time
one time when the guy was lining up for
the field goal i think he missed it too
no who was that i don't know who that is
for some reason i'm thinking eric
parseghian or something like that but i
think he was a coach in notre dame let
me just uh
let me look up nfl films one time bill
you remember jerry glanville
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he goes this is all the five fifteen
dresses in black they're gonna overcome
my game plan
because this is the nfl which stands for
not for long when you're making those
[__] calls
all right rounds coach all right nfl
films one time brown's coach
sam ratigliano
yes that was him one time can i see a
picture can i see a picture of him i'll
dress like him and i'll take a picture
he actually you know who could do it
mark norman could probably do a good sam
reticuliano
and he's italian too which is hilarious
i just got to see the hairstyle
it's the wavy black clean shaven
oh wow dude
get out get get that first one there
that first one he's got the brown jacket
on
there you go
[Music]
i mean you look at that guy's face you
tell me that guy does not coach in
cleveland oh my god
you just see the pain in that city on
his face
dude oh my god bill dude i gotta get a
black wig and do that
dude i'm not gonna lie i'm sure he's
passed rest his soul but dude that guy
looks like he's a was it an otb many
times i'll tell you what makes no sense
how bushy his eyebrows are and his
forearm is and he still has a full head
of hair usually when a guy that guy's
that hairy
it's almost like it falls off your head
onto your eyebrows into your [__]
arms
he's he's still a live ball
oh okay good dude we gotta get him on
the podcast
pikachu cardiac kids with brian's sight
reggie rucker can we get the videos
can we get the video of him saying one
time or no
oh look
i gotta see that dude
[Music]
oh yeah
i mean this is yeah baby
the hands on the knees one time one time
one time baby one time
one time
come on baby one time i think he misses
it one time baby one time
one time oh that was just one
bill that reminded me one time you sent
me a video of a guy
watching his horse
do you remember that he's going good
uh
dude you sent it to me was i at that
thing the guy whipping his own ass
no
you you sent me a video of a guy
watching it
no there was a guy there was a guy he
was he was like mimenin
and he had his program he was going like
this and he was whacking his own at like
he was hitting the horse were you
smacking his own ass in a [__]
it was [__] i i've never seen
anything like you know how
i'm trying to think like sports you
[__] act out you know you do you know
like you i don't know if you like
bowling or something you do like body
english this guy was literally riding
the horse and taking his program
like
i don't know
are you looking forward andrew or no no
you are yeah if you could get that guy
dude
but one guy was just screaming the
horse's name and as the horse got closer
he started screaming the horse's name
louder and go god
god then the horse lost
oh is that sorry hope
it was yeah you just like yeah
hey come on
[Laughter]
there's something sad but awesome about
an 80 year old doing that
um
all right so while you're looking for
that we'll just uh
recap these teases guys hope you guys
join the teasers that we did
we have um
joe burrow
getting
getting one
and the new england patriots getting 10
and a half
against the bills
we got to smoke a cigar with joe burrow
one day yeah we do
we have the
philadelphia no no what did we do with
the philadelphia eagles
we teased them up we teased the
philadelphia eagles up to 14. i think
tampa is going to win that i like eagle
i don't think it went by that much
okay
and we teased that game with
the chiefs the chiefs getting
uh the chiefs minus six and a half
and we have the san francisco niners
getting nine in dallas
and the los angeles i don't know you
took the cowboys you took the cowboys
okay i'm sorry sorry see glitch uh the
cowboys we tease down the cowboys are
getting three at home yep
and the los angeles rams we teased down
six two so they'll be getting two and a
half is that right
at home in los angeles so those are our
teases for wild card weekend
um i'm interesting to i'm interested to
see if the patriots can knock them off
that's a possibility with belichick in
them
um that should be good man oh billy
billy's going to be watching that
you're going to be watching that game uh
yeah i think uh
yeah it's they're a really really good
team they're a really good team what
would you do mac jones goes in there
against buffalo like 22 for 25 three
touchdowns 365
he's definitely doing the bills beat us
the last time
um they're a really good team and they
have a really good coach and they're
playing at home and they're sick of
[__] losing and uh yeah i picked a
packer i never agree with dan
shaughnessy but he said something this
week the pats can't play from behind and
that's kind of what it's looking like so
um it's gonna be one of those deals
where if we have to play catch up with
josh
allen and [__] was it stefan diggs
uh that's shaunicy guy that shauna c guy
saying that the first year with the new
[__] like you made the playoffs
that's such like a negative sports
writing thing to say i think
well i mean that's he's kind of hung his
hat on that
yeah he's the guy that wrote the curse
of the babe and he's also the guy like
after the curse of the babe was over the
next year we had a bunch of injuries in
september and the yankees were coming on
he was like is the curse back
yeah he's just like what one year he's
the type of he's trying to sell books
yeah he's the type of guy if you handed
him a bunch of cash you're like where am
i going to put this
i don't have enough room to put it in my
pocket um well in defense of him there
was a lot of boston sports rides like
new york sports writers it's like are
you actually secretly a yankee fan are
you secretly from like fans of other
teams because all you guys do is try to
pull apart
like i love when they speculate that
there's problems in the locker room and
[__] and it's just like
it's like so what if there is they'll
work it out they're men shut up
yeah somebody yes somebody else is the
last thing and then we'll go on to the
thing somebody asked john mara they go
like this because john marron the new
york giants actually talk about that for
a second john mara and the new york
giants decided even though they said
they were gonna just get rid of the gm
and keep joe judge because
they actually decided that the last few
games of the giants was such a debacle
that they're going to start over they
fired joe judge yesterday and then the
owner john mara comes out and the
questions and he's such a gentleman
about it and the questions are like one
kid goes so do you think like this is a
desired place for a gm you know
considering that you might have a
quarterback issue and the coaches have
been in and out all the time and that's
my question yes it is it's new york city
is this a desirable place to be a sports
writer and he wasn't even he wasn't even
arguing like that he goes well you know
i think this is a desired job you know
he's like we've been a little unstable
lately but you know i think we've had
some
success [__] question ever and it
really bugged me but um you know i'm
excited new gm new coach coming in we
might hold on and see if they get a i
would be such a [__] to those people i'd
be like do you think you're desirable
you think the woman that ends up with
you is truly going to be happy like
you're you're the prince that you
dreamed of
riding up on that white horse with your
laptop
oh
bill we get the sadder to do the song oh
let the saturday night special
make some money for you that's my
favorite part
all right
so saturday night is the steelers
no patriots bills bills
oh oh
okay so
we got money line we got under the under
rover's 44.
what up dude you want to move that up to
50 bill what do you think bill this is
your team you know better than me this
is an afc rivalry you know better than
me
oh
[__]
i don't know uh
about this game let me just let me think
about this for a second i could see
this being a shootout
i just know
first one was a weird game with the wind
and the next one we played with them and
then i believe they pulled away in the
end
uh i don't know
what are you thinking for like the over
under
i see both teams in the 20s but i i see
like a 26 20 game i see something like
that man i i don't know
i think we tease it down and take the
over let's tease it to 38.
okay i like that
yeah
our our saturday night special going
into the first week of the playoffs wild
card weekend buffalo bills at home
against the new england patriots we are
going to tease the under down to 38 and
take the over we are going to tease the
4.5 points the patriots are getting and
bring that to 10 and a half and we are
going to say that um uh juwan bentley is
going to get a sack
the patriots get a sack there you go
guys this has been um
this is the first week first week of
wild card weekend layoffs
playoff playoffs thank you guys for
listening and watching me
playoffs
uh all right man we will see you uh yeah
we'll see you going into what the
divisional yeah we'll see you going into
the divisional series next week take
care all right and there you have it
that is the uh
that is the the end the jimmy the greek
award congratulations to paul verzi
paul verzi getting it done the guy went
on a tear in december and he ran me down
the son of a gun
um all right that's it enjoy the music
here
picked out by the always
always fabulous
beverly hills his own andrew themeless
and um
afterwards we'll have a bonus episode of
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast enjoy
and have a great weekend i'll see you
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
january 13 2014
how you doing monday the 13th you know i
heard that one's bad luck too
oh with your [__] trinkets
huh what are you gonna grow up and just
just [__] man up lady and realize
that you [__] up your own life
you know you know those people they
gotta spin around three times and throw
some cookie crumbs over their [__]
padded shoulder
you know so so so something doesn't
something bad doesn't happen
i'd like to take all superstitious
people put them in a room
and after i'm done slapping them with a
[__] garden hose i just like to tell
them that listen bad [__] happens in
life
okay no matter what you got hanging
around your neck now i mean how many
times you [__] point your [__] toe
your left foot due south whatever the
[__] you're supposed to do it's still
gonna happen
still gonna happen balances out the good
[__] all right so why don't you stop
being such a [__] [__]
oh man i talked about that a long time
ago i don't care if you do it you don't
i'm gonna bring it back up
do you ever did you guys ever see that
was it jesus camp
no no no no it was one of those big
brother shows one of those shows one of
those one of those
one of those [__] reality shows you
know where they got a couple of meat
heads in there one of them's gay
the other has no was raised by wolves
and then there's a couple of hotties
there's never a fat chick
you know
all these people getting in trouble for
fat shaming
how about these reality shows was the
last time you saw a fat chick just
walking around in a thong in the big
brother house you're never gonna see it
you're never gonna [__] see it
all right the only time they put them on
fat people on a reality show if
if the show is about
i don't want to be fat anymore
you know
i can't think of one but anyways there
was this show
and there was some chick on it the
reality show and anytime she had some
big challenge coming up she had to climb
into a [__] tree house
you know without tipping over the
cupcakes whatever the [__] they're
supposed to do there's some
angry at his dad hosts
now the blue team is slowing down what
the [__]
you know that guy from the island show
what is it called dangerous
a survivor
i [__] hate that show my wife watches
that goddamn show and we both sit there
laughing he's such a [__]
i don't know what happened he never used
to be that way i think he's sick of
doing it
one of those like be careful what you
wish for
like i mean at first it was his dream
job he comes home to his wife honey i
got this idea for a show i'm so [__]
sick of being out here in hollywood
stuck in this goddamn traffic you know
trying to get the other side of the 405
to audition to be fifth banana and like
a [__] chapstick commercial i don't
want to do it anymore
okay
i'm thinking uh uh i'm moving to
colorado springs and opening up a
[__] burrito joint what do you think
and she's sitting there going well why
don't
okay i understand you're stressed
um
go ahead just say it [__] all over my
dream you never support me anyways
that's not what i'm saying so what i'm
saying just
just you know you're very emotional at
this point this is very this is extreme
um
why don't you create your own show
you know
why don't you just
i don't know you like islands
don't you
guys kind of do like islands right then
they just sit there at their little
[__] starving artist kitchen table
they come up with this [__] show
that puts him on a goddamn island he
gets paid he's on tv
he's going to get
you know groupie island chest hair [__]
right
chest hair mean chicks who like tanned
up chests
with
with with hair on it
and he gets his job
but then they're like well wait wait no
no before that they're like well i don't
know how to write a script
and like well why don't we just
make it like a game show well that's
[__] stupid right he's all pissed
again and he wants to go back to the
burrito but she kept him in the pocket
like every great woman by an every great
man kept him in the pocket and somehow
at some point
probably halfway through the second
joint they [__] realized wait a
minute what about the real world
we'll do a reality show
right
we'll take 10 [__] morons and we'll
stick him on this goddamn
island all right and they'll they'll uh
they'll play hopscotch and [__]
connect four or whatever the [__] we got
to do
and the last [__] so whatever so he
gets the goddamn job
i don't know where the [__] i am in this
anymore so he gets a [__] job and now
this he's out there
and there's this that tipping point
where after a while you're just you're a
human being and you just get [__]
bored
of the same [__] routine the exact
way that i ended up in this business or
one of the main reasons maybe why i
travel so much is because one of the
most depressing feelings i ever had when
i back when i was in the matrix and i
actually had a real [__] job
you know i got up in the morning and
made myself a little tuna fish sandwich
a little plastic thing with some fritos
toss an apple in there
walking out to the car right
the grease from the fritos already
making that pit stain on my little brown
bag
as i walk up to my rusted out car hoping
it's going to start
hoping i don't have a problem with the
[__] alternator
right
there was nothing more [__]
depressing
than that that moment when i was had
been there for a year
and i was actually sitting there going
one year ago i was right [__] here i
hated that [__] and i think that that
[__] island dude he's not an island
dude he's a mainland dude on the [__]
island i think it's [__] with him at
this point
okay he doesn't give a [__] anymore he
just wants to get through
those stupid [__] obstacle courses
because he wants to get he's going
[__] nuts out there
he's already he guys been out on that
[__] island since like 1999.
all right at this point he's kind of
like those japanese soldiers that didn't
know world war ii ended and they didn't
find him till 1974. that's what the [__]
is going on with this guy so i i don't
know if you've noticed
but nia watches that show religiously
and with every season that [__] guy
gets angrier and angrier
now the red team they need to pick it up
he just sits there [__] i just realized
she's still sleeping upstairs
um what the [__] it's 5 or 10 in the
morning
you know at that point i'm allowed to
[__] drill a jackhammer i can't do a
[__] podcast
this is how i win arguments i i rehearse
what i'm going to say before i get into
them
you know and then during the argument i
act like i'm fishing like i don't
already have the information
and that's how i went
um anyways this is the monday morning
podcast everybody and uh
i don't even know what the [__] i was
talking i was talking about uh
superstitious people
um
you guys like when i do stevie wonder
could that have been any whiter
you know what i think i'm gonna do that
down in koreatown tonight i'll probably
get a standing ovation
um golden globes everybody
look i went from reality tv
what was i talking about talking about
fat chicks and thongs
was that my point ah there's never any
point to this [__] thing
the point is is for me to talk for an
hour and just somehow eat up an hour
your monday that's what it is whether
it's in the morning or it's in the
afternoon one of my favorite things
about this podcast is that it is called
the monday morning podcast in the amount
of [__] people who so selfishly feel
that it's their monday you know like
they're doing any sort of heavy lifting
on this podcast other than downloading
it for [__] free
all right why don't you and your index
finger go [__] yourselves this is my
monday morning it's 9 56 a.m where i am
and i am recording this [__] podcast
all right how many times have you sent
something fedex second day to get there
before nine and it doesn't get there
till three three in the afternoon are
you one of those [__] that tries to
hold fedex
you know try to get you know three
dollars and a quarter taking off your
little [__] envelope
not even thinking that you sent
something from san diego to bangor maine
and isn't that [__] amazing because
me as a person
who actually gives a [__] about getting
there can't get there that quick
can i i don't think i can i don't
[__] know it's amazing because the
letter doesn't care
it doesn't have a dog in the fight it's
[__] led up just sitting there
waiting to biodegrade
so
i cut him some slack
jesus christ can you tell i got a bunch
of [__] to do today none of this is
going to make sense
um let's talk about the golden globes
so uh oh yesterday
yesterday i went i saw the uh the
i saw the wolf the wolf of wall street
i saw with joey roses
and my lovely wife nia
i went down and i saw i saw the movie we
were in the movie theater we watched it
together it was it was a great moment
because me and and [__] uh
deroza love scorsese all of his movies
we quote him all the [__] time versi
does it too yet i've never gone to a
brand new
score stacey scorse scorsese however the
[__] you say it they were saying it
different last night at the golden
globes and he didn't have an angry look
on his face so i think i've been saying
it wrong of course scorsese
um
we went down and saw his uh
saw his movie had a great [__] time
um
and then i went home and i said all
right i'm gonna [__] uh
oh what was my point oh my point was oh
yeah me and joe we're gonna start doing
the uninformed show again
all right we're in the same city we're
going to start it out doing it once a
month
and for those you never heard of it it's
basically unoff the uninformed show no
reading no research just strong opinions
and basically me and joe we go off for
an hour
on a particular topic
just coming from the hat
making all kinds of ignorant statements
and then when our hour of ignorance is
is over we bring in an expert on
whatever topic we were discussing and
then he basically tells us how [__]
stupid and wrong we are then that's the
show
all right if you can't do the math on
that i can't help you um
so we were getting excited talking about
that
and uh so then later on last night later
i decided i was gonna uh i'm gonna be a
good [__] person here and i'm gonna
watch the golden globes
right
i i watched the first playoff game and
then i recorded the second one playoffs
and uh so i watched the uh i watched the
charges versus the broncos
i watched that game in about 50 minutes
it was [__] phenomenal
it was [__] phenomenal and i already
forget the name of the chargers receiver
who just [__]
is gonna be a goddamn superstar
whatever the [__] his name was he really
really
impressed me on the uh on the big stage
on the big stage there so uh oh [__] it
let's talk nfl football i'm already into
it what do you what do you say what do
you say there football fans
all the favorites won as far as i can
tell
you know
like versey said the dumbest thing ever
he goes patriots
broncos in the afc championship dude i
called it
oh percy going out on a limb again
um
i'll take brady and manic
i think they're gonna do something but i
actually i didn't believe in the
patriots
i still can't i can't believe how
[__] well they're playing
with all the injuries that they've had
obviously going into denver is going to
be a tough uh tough game i traveled so
much
i think we beat him this year
yeah we did that's right they were up
big and then we came back and beat all
right so now we're gonna go in their
house and they're gonna beat us that's
how it works
that's how it works and the one i can't
understand
is uh this is going to be a tough one
seattle and san francisco because you
got the division rivals
you never know which way it's going to
[__] go
it's like the patriots no matter how
good they are
every year they're gonna lose to the
bills the jets and the dolphins two out
of three of them they're going to lose
to them like once
at least unless they get some juggernaut
of a [__] team but i'm just saying
they see you twice they know what you do
and every other [__] cliche out there
but i still i'm sticking with seattle
i'm blocking out that [__] douche
chill 12th man
musical that's going on oh we registered
an earthquake every [__] game
uh they go in the way of the raider fans
too more and more people they're
starting to become characters they're
starting to paint their faces it's just
somebody
the real you know they have the real
housewives of [__] atlanta i need the
real seattle seahawks fans of seattle
you got to tell those people to leave
the capes at home
you know every team has got that one
jackass that paints his [__] face
shaves his head and sticks the emblem on
the side of his head everybody's got
that one [__] jerk off and it's fine
it's fine to have one but there is a
tipping point in the stance
where there's too many of them
and they start bringing their signs we
were making fun of that [__] like
if you have end zone seats and you make
a bullseye sign
just how [__] unoriginal you are
that's right up there with the defense
sign
and the john 3 16.
i don't even read the bible
okay i don't know how to make songs like
that i don't know what words to use
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry
um
yeah how about an original [__] sign
you run in the milk every day [__]
[__]
sitting around talking about this
comic's not original that movie's not
original this is derivative this guy
ripped off this and look at you look at
you guys
he got all [__] weak
probably more than a week you probably
got the tickets for your birthday or
some [__] you have all that time to come
up with a [__] sign and you make the
defense sign
why don't you just put on a stupid hat
and then act like you're the crazy guy
despite the fact that you're a faithful
married father of three who pays his
taxes on time
well i'll tell you just something
happens when he puts that hat on we
don't know what he's gonna do he's
paying for his pretzels just like you
are ah there's nothing i hate more than
the character [__] the fan
that's become a [__] character
ah
right there i swear to god you know what
they should do to everybody who does
that they should pull them out of the
stands and make them throw a ball in
public
okay and when you watch the the lack of
whipping motion you know that power a
chick throws a ball that didn't have
brothers
you know what i mean
the way they throw the arm motion
of a girl throwing
who didn't have a dad that stuck around
and taught how to throw a ball
it literally looks like cheap animation
like it skipped a couple of frames it's
just the worst thing i would put my
money down put your money down i put my
money down
that if you took one of those [__]
face painted douche bags out of the
[__] crowd that's how they would
throw a ball i could be wrong
i could be wrong
i don't i i like the way it used to be
when you go to a [__] game back in
the day you went to the game maybe you
had some old shitty hat from your team
you know
and that was it
and the rest you had your stupid jack
you just the rest of you you know other
than your [__] hat
when you walked out of that stadium and
your alcohol level you could you could
go to work you just [__] looked
regular and you went there
you drank beers you got drunk and you
scared kids that's what you did in the
old days okay you pissed in a giant
horse trough and there wasn't any sushi
and there wasn't this [__] dumb ass
music what did i i went to a game recent
i went to the bruins uh la kings game
and uh
the bruins played like they really
enjoyed their time out here in l.a
do you how many times i've gotten burned
on that any boston fans who are coming
out here
um
and you know
you get homesick and everything so
anytime the celtics
the bruins or the red sox go down to
[__] anaheim play the angels or
whatever unless they do some inner
league [__] with the dodgers you're
gonna go
um
i gotta warn you
actually specifically with the uh
with with the bruins and the celtics
i gotta warn you okay don't buy
expensive tickets because i'm telling
you especially
with hockey
these poor bastards have to go play they
gotta go do a road trip
in the middle of february
through cal winnipeg calgary
edmonton
and vancouver
if that's just [__] kill me i would
be a raging alcoholic
if i had to do that so by the time they
come down to these sunny [__] cities
they got cabin fever
i'm telling you
or it's just you know la's got some of
the best looking women out here
they're famous i'm telling you they
don't play i can't believe the kings
it took them this long to get good
i would think that they would [__]
destroy all east coast teams and
canadian teams
other than maybe vancouver because they
don't [__] like each other
i don't know the amount of times i spent
like 80 100 bucks through stubhub to
watch the celtics play the clippers back
when the clippers sucked
um and i would watch the big three come
in there and just get smoked
that's [__] brutal so i'm just saying
all right just be careful with your
money out here just get the upper deck
[__] don't wear any of your stuff
it just go there dress like you're
[__] going to work or something and
then just cheer your team and it's great
if your team wins they win if they lose
you walk out of the stadium
you know and you don't have to listen to
anybody take it to that next level that
makes you want to throw a [__] punch
and then you're going to get stomped by
the neck tattoo guy it's just a
different thing out here it's not fun
it's not a fun place to see a game out
here they take it to a uh
they're just at a different level
you know like when you sit around giving
each other [__] yeah look at your shirt
blah blah your shirt's too tight and all
that crap and there's somebody yeah at
least my mother isn't dead there's
always like that person that's what west
coast fans are
anyways the [__] was i talking about
um oh nfl football so i still think it's
uh
it is seattle's
i just think that that that
i don't know
i just like the way they play they got
marshawn lynch is a [__]
was the last time
he didn't get hit three times before he
went down
i
cannot get that [__] guy down
all right that defense is insane
can you tell i've been on the road for
so long i can't even [__] name
anybody's name they have beautiful
uniforms no i just think out of the way
they're playing and i i don't think that
uh
i think they match up well
with the broncos i don't know about the
49ers this is their super bowl they get
by the 49ers i'm i'm i'm saying they're
winning it
they beat the 49ers they're going to win
it because uh
i just their defense is better than the
broncos and i think with marshawn lynch
they can [__] chew up the clock and
if peyton doesn't have the ball in his
hand what the [__] is he gonna do and i
think peyton gets frustrated
when he goes up against really uh
physical aggressive receivers
at least he did back in the day
when that's what we had on our team um
and who knows if the patriots go there
jesus i'll just be [__] thrilled that
we made it i really will be and
everybody's giving me [__] dude how can
you coming down on your own [__] team
i don't know because we lost our whole
[__] receiving corps
we lost all these guys on defense i'm
stunned that they've been able to do it
once again i'm saying it i'm telling you
right now tom brady's had one of the
best [__] seasons he's ever had
working with what he's working with all
right with that i have no idea who's
gonna win next week i hope we [__]
win but uh
you know i feel like you know we beat
them last time
and uh
i don't know i was really impressed with
denver's defense too so
who the [__] knows whatever all i know
is they're to be great [__] games
and i'm watching every second of it all
right and that's the deal that's all i
got to say about that all right let's do
a little bit of advertising here this
week
a little bit of [__] advertising
oh geez
where am i all right
all right dollar shave club everybody
guess what for a couple of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door
not only does it save you a ton of cash
it saves you from trudging to the
drugstore for a pack of blades
all right
because with dollar shave club for a
couple of bucks a month amazing quality
razors that are delivered right to your
door that's right no more wasting time
and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks
every time you buy razors no more
getting caught behind the junkie who
finally decided to buy toothpaste down
at the frigging cvs
no more of that the old people want to
develop their film and get an ice cream
right and there's only one person
working there which is a rule now at
every drugstore there's only one person
there's only one registered open there's
one person on the floor and they're
hiding down near the alcohol
you don't want to deal with that and get
screwed on the price what do you do go
to dollar shave club everybody here is
getting their dollar shave club blades
and you should too and here's another uh
genius idea try replacing your old
shaving cream with dr carvey's evening
shave butter
from dollarshaveclub.com trust me your
face will thank you later
don't waste time at the drugstore behind
the lady paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner
keep your stress level low when your
bank account balance high shave time
shave money go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash burr
there you go
owen in the bottom says note please
personalize areas highlighted in yellow
well all i have is black and white here
so i feel like i did the right thing
uh legal zoom
legal zone some things like starting a
business or protecting your family with
the will aren't like your other new
year's resolutions you can't afford to
blow them off
instead of less snacking and more
exercise put them at the top of your
list
legal zoom that sentence does not make
sense instead of less snacking and more
exercise put them at the top of your
list put what at the top of my list
it's got to be legal zoom right they
wrote the copy ah let's plow ahead
legalzoom helps you incorporate or form
an llc with their simple questionnaire
starting at just 99 this is for all you
dreamers in your cubicles if you want to
start your business and protect yourself
this is it you can do it for 99 bucks
over 1 million entrepreneurs have done
it and 90 percent of customers recommend
legalzoom to friends and family you
could also create a will starting at
just 69 bucks or even a living trust
quickly and easily and get peace of mind
protection for only 69 dollars you can't
beat it no surprise fees no hassles no
headaches legalzoom step-by-step process
was created by a team of experts in law
and technology law and technology bang
zoom legalzoom is not a law firm but can
connect you with a third party attorney
and provide you with self-help services
from wills to business formations
trademarks powers of attorneys and more
go to legalzoom.com for even more
savings type in bur burr into the
referral box at checkout don't put off
the things you need to do go to
legalzoom.com now and use the discount
code burr that's legalzoom.com discount
code burr all right there you go that
was pretty painless this week
um
anyways
okay so i watched the uh the golden
globes
i watched most of them last night
um
as you do
you know
i was watching all the football
this weekend so i figured you know i got
to come her way i'll sit down i'll go
come and watch it with me
i want you to watch it with me
so i sat down and i watched the golden
globes
and um
it wasn't it wasn't bad
for an award show it wasn't bad the
hosts were great
they were funny
and uh the only thing that bugged me was
the amount of people who went up there
and when they won a golden globe like oh
my god i can't i have a i can't wait
i was not ready for this okay let me get
ready for it you were [__] nominated
jesus christ had your [__] bets
the amount of people that went up there
and said oh my god
i can't believe this
i i i'm not prepared i didn't think i
was gonna [__] win
you know
like some [__] backup goalie just
sitting there and all of a sudden
you know
i'm not getting in this game we're up
five nothing
this is a joke
you know you start texting on the bench
and all of a sudden the starting goalie
pulls his groin now you got to go out
there what the [__]
unbelievable do you see how might you
want to see how it's done you should
have seen michael douglas
the way he accepted his golden globe
first of all for some [__] reason
anybody who won a golden globe last
night was seated like 75 yards away and
you had to [__]
walk all the way down and then
backstage and then come walking out
from backstage like everybody didn't
just see you get up from your table
so what does he do he assesses the
situation like jesus christ is taking
too [__] long
so the second he gets called he doesn't
go oh my god oh my god do you believe it
and you know clasp his hands together
and then slam him down into his lap
you know the hackie i've just won a
reward in show business move he didn't
he got up and he starts jogging
right
like a wily veteran a grizzled veteran
who knows how to utilize the clock he's
running up to the offensive line
he [__] gets on the stage he's he
goes into a great story about how he got
the part he thanked everybody before the
[__] oboe player even started it was
phenomenal
it's like watching joe montana
joe montana run the two-minute offense
it was great he did everything but say
john candy's in the crowd
right that's probably a bad joke because
he could have been in the crowd he would
have been in the crowd if he didn't die
ah [__] you know what it was a great
analogy right up until then but other
than that
i swear to god like 40 of the people
went up there and said oh my god i can't
[__] believe it what do you mean you
can't [__] believe it
what do you mean you're not prepared
didn't the fact that you got nominated
months ago or weeks ago
it's like a [__] 50 second they give
you like a minute
you know who you're supposed to think
right
is that just like what you're supposed
to do you're supposed to have false
humility false humility so you said if i
ever win a golden globe i'm not going to
be [__] modest at all
[Laughter]
i'll just be up there talking [__]
just before i even get up to the podium
that's right that's right
that's right
i'm not gonna come up here and pretend
to be modest dude i [__] crushed it
this year
do you see what i was working with
you see that horseshit that they put on
the paper that i bring to life
attention to me alice
that was supposed to be me yelling at mb
davis
jesus christ
i did i don't know what the [__]
i had to keep walking out there was some
zombie that went up there
first of all she sat for [__] a
minute looking around just milking the
whole [__] moment you know
and she was the classic
old actress right she had the body of a
23 year old and in the face
of a mummy
[Laughter]
you know go [__] yourself if you think
that's too mean all right
dress and act your goddamn age with the
[__] shoe polish in your hair coming
down there looking like a sexy scarecrow
anyways
so she [__] comes down there like
something out of a horror movie
i i literally i had to walk out of the
room i have this thing
not only do i hate bombing i can't stand
watching people bomb
i it makes me uncomfortable i had to
walk out nia sat there with her hand up
to her mouth
and i don't know what this woman was
doing
at one point i heard she asked another
actor to stand up in the crowd for
inspiration
i'm sure everybody's ripping her apart
on the [__] internet but jesus christ
just go up and say thank you
i'm psyched this is great
i'm going to make way more money now
because i have one of these
women who are completely out of my
league might actually do a little double
take when i walk down the street thank
you so much
i'm going to hold this thing under my
chin like i'm telling a ghost story
so the gold is reflected off my face
[Laughter]
thank you to everybody writing the [__]
that i said thank you for editing it
thank you for making
hey go [__] yourself what's up to the
band and you're out how [__]
difficult is that
i'm not saying you won't be nervous
i don't [__] know
all right i can't believe i can't
believe
you know like you were at a [__]
chinese restaurant a bunch of balloons
came down from the ceiling
okay i just i had no idea
really you just walk around dressed like
that
you didn't notice the other celebrities
in the room
why do you have to pretend you're not
[__] psyched
anyways
um
that's why i love when cuba gooding won
the oscar
and he started running around like some
[__]
soccer mom
that just won a new winnebago or
whatever the [__] they drive it was
minivans
or the publishers clearing house just
showed up at his house that's what the
[__] you should do
right gives a [__] anyways
you you watch how i handle it at the
podcasting awards
[Laughter]
do they i think they have those have
those
when it's time to change
um they actually have podcasting awards
they should have you accept them like
[__] uh over skype
you know this you shouldn't be in uh in
the flesh should you
should we just be voices
um all right let's plow ahead here
golden globes what did i want to talk
about here
oh yeah i started doing yoga this year
i'm doing a nice long pause here as i
wait for every guy who's listening to
this to say a couple of homophobic
things
um
and i bought these great stretchy pants
that i wear and a half shirt
you know because you really want to be
like don't judge me but you really just
want to like
you don't wanna feel like
um
you don't have like loose clothing on
you know
you wanna feel like you're being held
sorry i'm just trying to put a
disgusting image in your head
of me with yoga pants and a half shirt
on yeah think about that
you know
my pasty white belly
muffin top hanging over
all right
so of course i can't just do a little
bit of yoga and get my you know
stretch out my [__] spine after all
these hours i've spent on airplanes
my [__] you know
all in nothing stupid attitude in life
is i go for i'm gonna start doing yoga
again this year because i haven't done
it like three [__] years
um
i immediately just go from i'm gonna
start doing yoga too i'm going to do 150
hours of yoga this year which translates
to three hours
a year which translates me also going
what about years uh weeks when i'm on
the road and i won't have a chance to i
need to build up extra time so i can
stay ahead of it you know like one of
those sci-fi movies where you need that
energy life force on your [__]
bracelet right i'm trying to get extra
extra guys
like you're playing like a video game so
of course i go too far and i [__] i
think i i slightly hyper-extended my
goddamn knee
what an [__]
i do this all the time if i'm gonna
start playing drums i play drums too
much end up hurting my [__] shoulder
or my hand
i i i don't know i don't want my [__]
problems
i think that's why i succeeded as a
comedian because there's no way to like
physically hurt yourself as a stand-up
comic you're just standing there talking
right i guess you could act something
out so much that you accidentally throw
yourself off the stage but you could
still come up and do it the next show
right
i don't know
anyways
so
yeah i'm too old to lift
i'll lift a little bit but what happens
is you're still eating like [__]
then you just get that i'm still lifting
middle-aged body
we where we have a shirt on you can kind
of see that there's shoulders and
there's pecs there but like your belly's
still sticking out
right
you know those guys and then they always
have some sort of wallet chain
i don't want to be that guy i really
don't want to be that guy so
anyways
we'll see
we'll see what happens
now why do i always [__] do that you
know from [__] day one i'm gonna do
yoga and within three days i'm trying to
do like a [__] full split
and then i get hurt hurt and then i'm
just you know what happened i smoked a
cigar last night i got to stop with this
[__] [__] you know what's
at my age
what's really scary is i lose a drinking
buddy every week at my age at 45
they just drop in like flies
the wife says i have to cut down i got a
fatty liver i got a kid i can't [__]
do it anymore
all right all right i'm gay and that's
why i was drinking all these years all
of those [__] things
you know
there's like nobody left
two of my buddies i lost two guys this
week
telling me i gotta stop there's
something wrong with my stomach and i
got a fatty liver
and all i'm thinking is how come i'm not
feeling anything
well probably because i never got my
liver checked out you don't feel
anything right you just walk down the
street one day
with your [__] uh
wallflower nose
damn my little chickadee right and then
all of a sudden you just do a face plant
and it's over is that how
you die cirrhosis
cyrosis cirrhosis scorsese i don't
[__] know um
yeah i gotta lay off i'm i'm done with
[__] cigars
i'm done with those things man those
things are right it's like sucking on a
bus tailpipe
just damn i didn't inhale
oh great so i just get [__] mouth and
throat cancer what am i an [__]
i gotta stop this [__]
it's the hardest thing about being an
adult is you have to be your own [__]
parent
you know when you were a kid
you know your parents were there to stop
you from eating a whole sleeve of
cookies you you the second you move out
you can do whatever the [__] you want
you can literally be doing heroin as
you're eating [__] cookies and
there's nobody there to say
stop
it's [__] annoying
i gotta lay off man
i can't do it though i just can't seem
to get you know what it is it's all
these social things football games
coming up going a hockey game ah it
starts tomorrow it starts tomorrow and
then last night you know
joey rose's got me a great [__]
bottle of this this
[__] i don't know japanese scotch
and i'm like well i gotta try it and of
course it was absolutely delicious now i
gotta have a [__] cigar with it
i'm sitting out on my porch
with my red sox robe on my bathrobe is
also my smoking jacket
because i'm an environmentalist
and i'm sitting out there smoking
there's nothing dumber than smoking a
really good cigar
when you're cold
it's another thing too this is a bad
time of year to smoke a cigar because
you can't smoke anywhere inside they
smell like [__] unless you're in a cigar
bar and then you're in there with like
50 other guys
in this in in you know
it just feels like you're in a walk-in
closet with a car on
after a while your eyes are burning i
can't even do it you know what it
reminds me of is back in the day when
people could smoke
in comedy clubs
and um
it was unreal by the time you got to it
you had to do three shows
or even two shows back then because
everybody seemed smoked back then
there would there'd be like a cloud
of smoke
you know by but at the beginning of the
second show because it was still left
over from the first show
and i just remember like my eyes would
be burning
when i got off stage in the second show
i'd have to go to the bathroom and like
flush him out with water and then i'd go
home
and i actually learned
to take a shower the night before
you went to bed because i always
remember the next morning i would wake
up and i'd take a shower and the water
came over my head i would just smell
the smoke like someone was smoking next
to me
so i imagine even that how bad smoking
is i can even imagine that being around
a bunch of people who are smoking and
then laying in bed with their smoke in
your clothes and in your hair
is somehow affecting your health it's
just bad
i i'm giving away my cigars i'm [__]
i can't say i'm done done with them but
i'm pretty much done with them what i'm
going to do is when i go to other
countries i'll smoke a cupid cigar
that's what i'll do and then i'm not
bringing a bunch back because then you
go oh [__] i got to smoke these these
are cubans i don't want them to go bad
right
and then you don't have a humidor
because you don't want to get sucked
into the habit and then what happens is
your [__] cigars are going bad
it's a nightmare
um
i'm gonna get a bunch of text first
world problem
no it isn't
cuban cigars are made in a third world
country so go [__] yourself
isn't that is that considered a third
world country
what is exactly a third world country a
country that we're oppressing is that
what makes them third world
it isn't just south america is it
ah christ now i gotta look it up and
there's a bunch of people laughing at me
right now but if i actually asked you to
give me a [__]
intelligent definition
you couldn't third world
countries
wait third world definition let's go
with that first
third world
okay according to wikipedia
the term third world arose during the
cold war to define countries that
remained non-aligned
with either nato
with the united states or western europe
western european nations and their
allies representing the first world or
the communist bloc and that would be
with the soviet union the people's
republic of china oh cuba so cuba is not
third world because they align
themselves with the soviet union and
their allies representing the second
world war
so i'm guessing that we came up with it
because we're the first first world
we're number one
all the commies are ranked number two
and then a distant third
you know
so based mexico
according to this chart
all of central america all the way down
to south america except there's one
in south america
that isn't what the [__] is that i don't
know what that is it's just north of
brazil
what is that burns in allen what's the
name of that [__] country down there
cakes and and biscuits
i don't [__] know um
let's let you know what i think it's
time mercifully for the questions this
week what do you say everybody
what do you say you ready you ready for
the questions for this week i
god knows i am oh really quickly i
didn't even get a chance to talk about
it did you guys watch that 60 minutes
thing last night and that [__]
jerk-off who's ratting out
alex rodriguez the henry hill
of that thing
all right i'm pulling a paul versi the
dude i call it i called it we're all
gonna be on roids
by the end of our lives
okay
and i'm gonna tell you why because the
same reason why you saw that sexy scarce
scarecrow walk into the [__] stage
the same reason why they got all these
diet pills and all this [__] grow
your hair back [__] because no one wants
to be old and decrepit
all right they're already giving the
[__] out that cinegenics is [__] hgh
as far as i can tell
um which is basically i researched i
said cinegenics
uh scandal
that's what i searched so of course
negative [__] came up about them
um we're all gonna be on it it's the
same way marijuana is gradually becoming
legal that's what's going to happen
with with steroids
garen [__] t
you know what's the coolest part of the
story
was they said a-rod texted this guy tony
whatever the [__] his name was
and
tony he said hey i got a big day
tomorrow what do you got
so he gave him the stuff the next day
everyone had like two doubles and a
single or something like that and the 60
minute guy goes oh
what did you think
after you
sent him your products and saw the
result
and he was going like
he basically said
that yeah we got the formula down
you heard the formula though and he goes
yeah it was like it was like shooting
fish in a barrel
so these guys are so advanced
in this illegal [__]
that i'm telling you they're going to
get it to the point where just like weed
where you can smoke it through like a
breathalyzer where all it is is just
basically the mist
of thc whatever the [__] that stuff is
that gets you high they're going to get
that with with steroids
all right and you're going to be 80
years old walking around feeling like
you can put your [__] fist through
the goddamn wall
it's going to be great
all right
and all of this this witch hunt on these
a-rod guys and all these guys who went
to jail and all that type of [__] that
people are going to look back and be
like well what was the problem
that's that's my prediction
provided an asteroid doesn't hit us
first
um oh by the way i retweeted something
that somebody sent me about uh
the denver
international airport
you know that there's basically uh that
they started to build it
and then they said well the structure's
wrong and then they rather than
destroying what they built they buried
it and then they built the airport on
top of it so all the conspiracy
theorists are saying this is a bunker
for all the [__] people who are going
to survive a nuclear holocaust or an
economic meltdown and there are a bunch
of weird paintings
on the on the walls
but if you really look at them
objectively it kind of looks more it's
more about world peace
oppression and then the children of the
next generation coming along and
oppressing the oppressors or stomping
them out and then there's no war no more
weapons you can look at it in a sunshiny
way or you can look at it
in a creepy way and i gotta admit a lot
of the
the artwork is uh pretty creepy i'll
send you guys a link to that [__] but
it's uh pretty interesting uh
i don't i love conspiracy theory because
i know
you know
i know how much i lie
[Music]
so why wouldn't they be so i i love the
speculation all right here we go let's
let me shut the [__] up and get on with
the uh the questions for the week
all right this one says ponies dot dot
dot i'm a [__]
t y bilton
yeah i'm a colts fan
um i guess that's a reference to some
guy who plays on the uh
on the [__] colts i don't know i
don't know anybody's name anymore i
don't know who shot i don't using that
he goes i'm listening to the
8 26 13 podcasts will you talk about the
difference between a pony and a horse i
was making fun of the fact that i i for
until i was like in my early 20s i
didn't realize that a pony's a pony and
a horse is a horse i thought a pony was
a small horse and the people down the
street had a pony my whole childhood
tied to the back of their [__] house
it was kind of cruel but uh i remember
driving by and finally when i was like
19 20 years old
my mother was driving and i was just
like when is that pony going to turn
into a horse and if i could
just go back and listen to the october
26th podcast of last year i explain it
way better the [__] look my mother
gave me before she started laughing at
me um
i still see it on her face every time
when i come home for thanksgiving
anyways i'm 23 years old he said 23 year
old american
english was my first language i have my
bachelor's degree i am going to law
school in august i scored higher on the
law school admission test than 97
97 percent
of potential lawyers and i just had to
look on wikipedia to find out that
ponies are indeed not young horses i'm
ashamed of myself
go [__] yourself at least i can read out
loud hey and it's okay look at least you
can read out loud dude you did all that
other stuff i can't do that you got to
take me out because you're also [__]
stupid
anyways he goes thanks for the free laps
your colorado spring show was amazing uh
go andrew luck well
he's going to the golf course there
buddy um
yeah for all you people out there pony
is a pony
and a horse is a horse
i guess uh a
small horse is a cult is that what you'd
call it
you know what's amazing is that i don't
know what it is and i never take the
time to look it up so i always sound
dumb in this conversation
okay advice on men
hey bumbling billy boo uh i'll keep the
question short to rescue you from the
english language
i get it i suck at reading out loud
he goes i'm a 20 oh she says oh my god
this is from a lady
i finally get a female to write in and i
trash her right out of the gate i'm
sorry sweetheart
she says i'm a 24 year old girl and i'd
like to know your best piece of advice
of understanding the human male species
many thanks but at the same time go [__]
yourself well i'm sorry you got to be a
little more specific
um i'll give you basically
generally speaking um
oh jesus christ what what do you want to
know
i would basically you want to learn how
to communicate with them better
um
yeah so you're doing the right thing
you're asking another person this is
actually a very smart question
rather than sitting around
with your female friends just going i
know right
what is what is that
god
you sit there at a [__] wine bar
whining
this is what you do
you go across enemy lines and you ask
you know a traitor like me to read from
the playbook
all right how guys
communicate
i can't say that we just say what we're
thinking because we we have liars and
passive-aggressive people and uh
meandering little man boys but generally
speaking uh the thing that confuses us
the most
i did a bit i can't remember if i did it
on the special but
one time i was driving
with nia
and i said hey i want to get a chocolate
shake we're going to buy this diner and
she freaks out she's like oh my god they
make the best chocolate shakes now i
know right she goes yeah and she just
goes oh my god that they're so big
she just kept saying they're so big
and after a while i'm thinking like
yeah like [__] how the [__] am i going
to drink this whole thing
and then immediately just clicked on me
it's like they're not big
they're standard size
wait a minute she wants half of my shake
but she doesn't want to seem selfish but
she doesn't want all the calories of the
full shake so rather but she doesn't
want to look like she's taking away 50
percent of my good time
so rather than telling me that she's
trying to mind [__] me into thinking
something that i drank a zillion times
with ease is now too big
you know what i mean
so that's how you guys communicate
i don't know how we communicate
because i can't just sit there and make
it seem like guys are heroes and well
they would be like listen i'm trying to
lose weight so uh can i have half your
shake
um
the only thing i tell you is you're 24
years old uh you shouldn't understand
them
you shouldn't understand guys but it's
hard for me to
i don't know what you're asking
please write back
please write back advice on men part two
just do that again just [__] right
back ask me something more specific and
i can help you out but it's great that
at 24 you're actually smart enough to
ask guys
to explain
um
let's see best piece of advice
here's a great piece of advice uh learn
how to cook
all right as stereotypical as that
[__] sounds i don't mean it in
a sexist [__] way
all right
i don't
don't be a slob
and learn how to cook
would put you ahead of 80 percent of
[__] women out there because for some
reason
somewhere along edith wharton over that
chick who showed the flag
making a guy a sandwich
became
this absolutely degrading [__] thing
to do
yet guys still have to hold the doors
and [__] buy drinks like why we don't
find that sexist reverse sexist or
whatever the [__] you'd call it
i remember one time i was downstairs i
don't know what the [__] i was doing
i was doing some pain in the ass job i
was cleaning out something in the garage
and without
me asking or anything nia came
downstairs
with this unbelievable sandwich she had
made
pickles toothpick in it the whole
[__] nine yards
and she brought like uh something to
drink downstairs too
and i stopped working and sat down and
it was one of the greatest
moments of our relationship
all right so that's it some advice i
would give you is guys are very very
simple and by simple i don't mean stupid
before you get on your [__] high
horse
okay
it's like an old school engine you open
the hood and everything's right there
rear wheel drive it's not turned to the
side
jammed into the compartment none of that
[__] it's just [__] basic
you just do that every once in a [__]
while
guys will think i have a keeper
and all you're doing is making a [__]
sandwich
and that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
have the right to vote it's [__]
unreal cooking and you're not even
cooking all you're doing is just
slapping [__] together you're building a
little [__] food house how difficult
is that
that's what i don't understand like i
guess i can't understand it but like
cooking a meal for somebody is one of
the greatest things you could ever do
for
all right i'll leave it at that so i
would say something simple like that
this is how simple guys are if you
actually every once in a while just said
hey you want a beer and you actually got
up and went to the fridge and got a beer
and brought it out put it in a [__]
frosted mug i mean personally speaking
i'm ready to go paint the house
because that little move there i feel
like a [__] king
that's all it takes that's all it takes
very simple
you know
let him head out with his friends once a
week
if they come over and they watch the
game and you're not into the game
leave go in the other room or be a good
[__] and hang
but don't ruin his good [__] time
jesus i'm on a roll here now
here's another one
uh
trying to limit the amount of horrific
[__] you're gonna drag him to now he's
he's obligated to go to some of it but
he has to have just set it up and just
say listen
there's a bunch of [__] that you do that
i'm not gonna be into right like
tailgating on a golf course peeing in a
porta potty before before a football
game that you don't give a [__] about i
don't want to be there for that so i get
to tap out of that
all right and then the guy he gets to
tap out of like
i don't know like what have i i tapped
out one time uh neil wanted to take me
to somebody's birthday party they were
having some [__] you know we're all
gonna dress like it's the gold rush or
the [__] prohibition era it's like i
don't want to [__] do that
and she gave me [__] and i was just i
don't want to do it and she let me out
of it we laughed about it
i actually went there without a costume
i mean i made a deal we made it we made
up we
made a deal
i think i told this story i'm [__]
punch drinking i never know what the
[__] i'm talking about
i showed up and i didn't wear a costume
which was hilarious because every other
guy was [__] dressed like charlie
chaplin and i show up
in street clothes and they're looking at
me like i'm a magician
and then i left early because that's
right because i would have watched the
celtics were playing the lakers in the
finals that year when we beat them
and i would have missed it
if nia wasn't so [__] cool so that's
that's what i would do and if you
actually do [__] like that
you know
you you put yourself
on this
solid ground with the guy that you're
with where now
there's no reason for him to be an
[__] to you or be mean to you because
you're being so nice to him it really
kind of works that way kind of feeds off
each other that's the best i can do
without a specific question all right so
there you go
and you know [__] everybody who's gonna
say that you know what i just said was
sexist you know go [__] yourself i don't
think it's
you know
you're on a date with your woman you go
and you open the car door for you still
do that [__] if i can do that you can go
get me a [__] beer christ it's a
twist off
what are you gonna hurt your wrist
yeah you know something that would be my
advice stop acting like a kicker
you know what just [__] annoys me
that every time a kicker makes a tackle
he gets hurt i just [__] i just don't
understand that
jesus [__] christ put some cream on
it and get back out there and [__]
throw your feet around
all right college rooma
uh
billy vanilli i like that one that's a
new one i can't wait to see you in
hamilton ontario i'm a 21 year old
college student who oh by the way i'm
hopefully going to have the uh the links
to those dates
in the next week or so everybody asking
about all of my my big canadian tour
in much
anyways uh this person says can't wait
to see you in hamilton ontario i'm a 21
year old college student who has been
having to deal with rumors
um i was a resident on dawn a couple
months back
which means i was responsible for
watching over first-year students in
their dorms during halloween i did hook
up with one of the first years
at a party i was at word somehow spread
but through classic broken telephone
that i got her drunk and banged her in
the elevator of her dorm
uh
consistently when i am at any
i think you meant to say consequently
when i'm at any social
gathering party kegger when i tell a
girl my name they immediately walk away
as if i'm some monster oh no i'm
thinking of transferring school as a
fair share of the campus thinks i'm that
creepy guy around girls any advice on
addressing this rumor with girls to stop
them from running for the hills would be
greatly appreciated
um
i don't know dude
did you do it
if you didn't do it
i don't know if you didn't do it i would
talk to the to the woman that you hooked
up with can you say listen can you
please tell people that i didn't get you
drunk
that that didn't happen
um
i don't i don't know i mean i don't know
if people are mature enough once it gets
out like that maybe she's embarrassed
that she hooked up with a
an older guy
i have no [__] idea
um
i don't know that's
i don't like those creepy sex ones
because now i'm i have to do this i have
to assume that you are innocent
who would get up somewhat look i gotta
tell you this who would get somebody
drunk and then [__] them in a public
place like that if you're doing
something under handily like that story
doesn't even make sense unless you
wanted to get caught
ah whatever
i don't know you know i don't know how
to get you it's once you get accused of
sexually weird [__] you kind of do have
to leave i guess
but then they win
i don't know dude that sucks i really
hope that you know you if you are
innocent i i really hope that uh you can
somehow get out of that because that's
that [__] thing where i always felt
like you know somebody gets accused of
some sort of sex crime like i don't
think that they should just put their
name in the [__] paper until they're
they're
they're convicted
because even then everybody in your
world is going to know about it
and uh if you didn't do it
once you're just accused of it you're
done
you're done it's [__] over i don't i
don't know and back in the day at least
you could you could go a couple states
over
you know change your name to [__] tj
or some [__] and [__] start a new
life you can't do it now every social
media the internet everything just
follows you around
um
you know what i would do it i would stop
going to parties
i would get sober and i would just say
you know
just and i i would i don't know stone
sober meet a nice girl and just say yeah
i mean i hooked up with this girl and
then somebody started this [__] rumor
and
i'm done with it
i don't want to do this [__] anymore i
don't i don't know how i honestly i
don't know how to get out of that jesus
these are [__] hard questions this
week
i don't [__] i mean i don't think if
you transfer you're admitting that you
were wrong
but where the [__] are your friends who
can back you up going oh that's [__]
you got nothing
you're just a loner
nah jesus i don't know all right
motorcycle through thailand jesus christ
if you rode a motorcycle through
thailand you're the toughest [__] guy
i know unless you're from there
uh
dear billy bud baxter
i'm i'm glad to hear your 2014
is starting off strong i remember you
talking a few weeks back about being
able to drive all to be able to drive
all things i've had that same philosophy
for a few years now and i've been
working towards learning how to do just
that i'm 25 hours into getting my
pilot's license and in november i took a
basic motorcycle driving course over a
weekend i think you have taken something
similar yeah i got a motorcycle license
a couple weeks after the course with no
additional motorcycle experience and
never having driven outside of a parking
lot i flew to thailand
jesus christ there i went to the
northern mountains and rented a 250 cc
dual purpose dirt bike and drove for
nine days around the mae hong song loop
the [__] is that though it can easily be
done in five or six days
google it if you feel like it it was
easily the best experience of my entire
life i was able to get out of the
the [__] show taurus claptrap areas and
see what the [__] was going on in the
day-to-day lives of a bunch of ties the
food was incredible the views were out
of this world the people are the most
friendly in the world see i have all
these stereotypes like i wouldn't want
to go up there thinking i get kidnapped
or some [__] and i was able to gain some
real chops
when it comes to riding a bike plus i
got to stop in a couple of small
tourist-based towns and met a beautiful
scandinavian girl oh and it didn't hurt
that 50
baht i don't know how to say it 1.50
american will get you all the food you
can eat
in 400 baht will get you a beautiful
bamboo hut in the middle of the goddamn
rain forest for the night i doubt anyone
will give a [__] about your stand-up in
thailand it's not you it's them
but you should definitely make a trip
out there and drive around on a rented
motorcycle i got tons of more
information if you're actually
interested thanks for the free laps come
to durham north carolina soon
uh and go [__] yourself
um
dude i would love to do that i'm just
afraid to go there's certain places
where you go i don't you get put on a
list
isn't thailand the one where [__]
perverts go to to bang little boys
you know we got enough thai food over
here they just assumed they don't assume
you're going over there to ride a bike
on the [__] ho chi minh loop or
whatever the [__] you just did over
there they they think you're going over
there for that but that sounds awesome
that is that is a bucket list
goal of mine i do i want to be in some
scenic place in another country on a
motorcycle
that i mean why wouldn't you want to
[__] do that
ride around pretend like you're tough
and you know how to fight that's that's
what i want to do
um
congratulations i never even heard of
that for the for those few listeners at
home if uh who are at your desk right
now and you don't want to [__] do
work
do work you don't want to be working uh
let me let me spell that out for you i
flew to thailand for not the mae hong
san loop m-a-e
hong as in hong kong h-o-n-g son s-o-n
loop
by the way what's up with [__] dr
evil in north korea feeding his uncle to
dogs
is that true
i kind of have to believe that because
it's not like they have to sway public
opinion liberal or conservative about
that guy
that fat jerk off
what the [__] is wrong with you if
you're listening to this because i know
your dad was a big movie fan and maybe
you want to rebel against your dad and
listen to podcasts if you're listening
to this
um
dude you're headed towards a an ugly
death you're not going to survive doing
[__] like that
that's not the way to do it i don't know
did your dad own the godfather trilogy
and you're trying to act like everybody
in your world is [__] mo green maybe
you have to do that you should have just
shot the guy dude
if you do stuff like that like the level
of fear that that put in me and i'm not
even in your country i'm already
thinking i i think my first thought
after i got over the wave of fear of
that was i have to kill this guy
if i lived in the country that's what i
would have two bullets one for him and
then i'd shoot myself just in case i did
you know what i'd shoot the dude
and then i would wait half a second and
if i didn't hear applause i would then
shoot myself
because i always felt if you took out a
guy who's just ruling with that level of
psychoness
um
that if you took him out
is everybody sitting there looking down
at the floor as he's saying the next
crazy thing he wanted to do that if you
actually took him out that on some level
people would be like uh the second you
did it would be like oh god thank god
you did it jesus christ i thought i was
the only one
um
all right i don't [__] know let me uh
let me move on to the last one here and
i gotta wrap this podcast up because i
got a i'm gonna do joe bartnick's
podcast today he's picking me up this is
a podcast monday baby all right drunk
girlfriend issue
hey uh oh wait a second i got to read
the last couple of ads here real quick
real quick real quick
reary crickery
stamps.com everybody oh
jesus stamps.com one great resolution
you can make for new for the new year
maximize every minute and every dollar
for your small business i know an easy
way to do that with what with stamps.com
think about how much time your waste
you've wasted going to the post office
driving there finding parking getting
around the homeless guy holding the door
stamps.com is the better way to get
postage just use what you already have
your computer and your printer to get
official us postage for any letter or
package um and then you put it out the
mailbox mailman picks it up bing bang
boom you're done with stamps.com
everything you would do with the post
office you could do it right there at
your own desk and at a fraction of the
cost for one of those expensive postage
meters i've been using stamps.com for
about three years it's so convenient any
crap that i'm selling after my shows i
run it through the little scale thing i
put a stamp on it and it's at the place
i've never had a problem and i'm a [__]
so if i can use it you can too right now
use my last name bur burr to get this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and f and up to 55 dollars free
postage don't wait
go to stamps.com before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the home page and type in bur that's
stamps.com enter bur b-u-r-r
if you're not doing that i i you just
you just enjoy life being difficult
all right e-voice
you're a business owner
but automatic automated phone systems
and secretaries are not in your budget
just yet and juggling incoming calls
yourself
makes it hard to look like a
professional basically you're biting off
more than you can chew here's something
that will dramatically help you make
more money in 2014 e-voice whether
you're a business of one or one hundred
e-voice will help you manage all of your
incoming calls with a toll-free number
dial by name directory and call routing
tools your business will sound like a
million bucks tank can't take a call
e-voice will transcribe the voicemail
and email it to you never be caught off
guard again and with e-voice you can try
it before you buy it right now just for
my listeners you can get a 60-day free
trial to e-voice go to evoice.com and
enter the promo code bill
at checkout take charge of your uh jesus
bill come on take charge of your
business and make more money in 2014. go
to evoice.com and enter bill at checkout
for your 60-day free trial that's
evoice.com promo code bill b-i-l-l
good lord people can you beat that
60-day free trial you just start in your
business
right out of the gate you sound like a
pro
i wish i had a business idea okay drunk
girlfriend issue this is the last one on
the on the podcast hey billy bob burton
um i'm a big fan of yours fellow
bostonian
suburb guy as well and i love the
podcast i have some relationship issues
that i'd like your input on if you would
be so kind you [__]
[Laughter]
all right i've been dating my girlfriend
for over four years i am 26 she's 25. we
moved in together in september 2013
because i thought things were going well
well we have some issues and i'm not
sure what to do besides the usual fights
over things where i think logically and
present my side of the argument
well with facts that are relative to the
subject and she rambles about how i'm a
mama's boy and have a small dick
um
well yeah i guess in other words you're
probably right so she's just
capitulated and i was just insulting you
granted this is your version of it
anyways he said my biggest issue is her
drinking more specifically how she acts
when she's drunk when we are drinking in
public
sitting not setting sitting with a large
group of people she drinks too much and
always blacks out this is typically
not a normal thing it only happens once
every few months but over the holiday
season it happened every weekend while
at company christmas parties hers and
mine friends houses and while on a pub
crawl i have two big issues with her
blacking out like that one is that it's
usually
she only drinks excessively when other
people mainly her [__] best friend
insists that my girlfriend should drink
a lot even though my girlfriend has a
very low tolerance for alcohol it's to
the point that her best friend will say
things to her like if you don't take
this shot i hate you slash you're not my
friend
jesus christ and she's being serious
i spoke with my girl repeatedly about
how i feel that that's not a good idea
or right to allow a friend to do that to
her and my girlfriend replies that she's
not going to say no to her best friend
no matter what jesus christ this is like
a textbook codependent relationship here
um
my second issue is that when she blacks
out once i get her in the cat the car or
cab to take her home she gets really
quiet and starts saying she hates our
relationship she hates me she hates
living with me she wishes we would break
up
among other similar things
once she sleeps it off and wakes up
hung over she has no recollection of
what she said to me the night prior and
she says that drunk words
they're drunk words and they mean
nothing oh god
i do not think that way it legitimately
hurts my feeling and his feelings and
has happened so often recently that i've
been weighing my options about whether
it's time to end this relationship and
move on i'm not sure i'm just being a
pushing need to get over it
or if i have legitimate gripe here dude
you totally have a legitimate right he
says i care about my girlfriend a lot
and until recently i was beginning to
think about proposing marriage to her at
some point
dude you cannot on any [__] level
propose to this girl with this [__] on
the table right now he said i had
planned it in my head that if we were
going to live together for two years
then we had the right stuff for marriage
uh with all this drinking stuff though
i'm not sure where to go if you have any
tips or advice i'd greatly appreciate it
go [__] yourself can't wait to see your
new special in 2014 hope you perform in
boston all right yeah dude um
first things first do not on any level
propose marriage to this woman
at all on any [__] level um
what you have to do is you got to put
your foot down
all right you have to say
both things that you brought up
provided you're being honest with me uh
you are 100 in the right and you have to
just say look
um you can't drink like that anymore
and
you can't have a relationship with your
friend like that anymore
actually you can because you are a free
individual but if you're going to be
then i i want out of this relationship
i'm not going to be with somebody who
drinks like that and more specifically
drinks like that because a friend is
making a drink like that and second of
all
you know i don't
i i don't
you know there's an expression out there
that what does it say uh a drunk man's
words or a sober man's thoughts
i don't know
i i would oh [__] this is bartnik hold
on one sec
hang on hang on joey b just wrapping up
the podcast i'll be outside in two
minutes okay
all right see you
um
yeah so i would basically uh
okay so let's just
compartmentalize this thing here okay if
that first issue just the drinking thing
i would just lay down the gauntlet you
if you if you want to be with me
and you know i'm not going to be in a
relationship with that going on that's
unacceptable i respect the fact if you
still want to do it but if you still
want to do it then you're moving out
around moving out and we're not going to
be a couple anymore because i'm not
tolerating that and you're well within
your right to do that it's a great thing
to say at 26 years of old to get some
sort of self-esteem within a
relationship and have some ground rules
with yourself this is your half of the
circle what do i want and what am i
willing to put up with where is my line
you found your line and you tell her
that that's where it is you don't have
to be a jerk you don't have to get angry
just say this is my line and i totally
respect if you want to live on the other
side of the line i'm just not going to
live with you doing that
um this other [__] where she gets she
says she hates her relationship and
wishes that you broke up um
if it happened one time whatever she
does that every [__] time i think
those are honest words and i honestly
would seriously consider getting the
[__] out of that relationship
um
i think you you guys have both been in a
relationship for a long time you got
into it when you were really young maybe
she still wants to see explore see what
the [__] out there
i have no idea but that is a major major
[__] red flag
um
and uh i don't buy it
and i also don't buy that she's 100
drinking like that because her friend is
making her do it
uh i think she wants to drink like she
maybe she's drinking like that because
she's not happy in the relationship i
don't know there's a bunch of major red
flags and you're 100 in the right you're
not being a [__] you're being [__]
mature and you're saying what you want
[__] this dude you don't want some drunk
with some drunk [__] friend
who then gets hammered and says they
don't want to be with you
when you dream is that your dream girl
when you sit there in fantasy kick this
[__] to the curb
i've had it with her i'm not even in the
[__] relationship you could do better
all right i'm not saying she's not the
one but she needs to grow the [__] up
don't say it like that but that that's
what i believe and that's that's my
thoughts and i'm sticking with it all
right my buddy's outside i'm being a
[__] i got to get off here uh
have a great week
go [__] yourselves and um
that's it i'll talk to you next week i'm
looking forward to some great football
all right see you
you